hey this you have to see uh pakistan
has this foreign minister named shah
mahmud qureshi
and this guy doesn't even try to hide
anti-semitic slurs
with the coded language and
sophisticated analogies and metaphors
that some try to use
to hide their anti-semitic slurs he just
drops an anti-semitic slur that jews
control the media
during the first 15 seconds of an
interview with cnn's biannual rodriguez
and you just have to see this now
sadly and we'll talk about this more
later this week there has been an
explosion of anti-semitic violence
around the us
in the last few days uh since the
israeli gazan ceasefire there are random
jewish people being attacked and beaten
across the u.s
incidents being investigated in los
angeles and new york and in many other
places people being punched kicked
beaten it's insane we're going what's
going on
we're seeing it on our channel where
we're having to ban
at this point it's hundreds of people
per day it's never been this bad
it's it's been bad it's never been as
bad as in the last week
uh anti-semitic comments and we're just
banning banning banning people on
youtube twitch facebook reddit twitter
etc etc
but this isn't random people like i
expect to get emails about jews control
the media
uh you know from bob in uh
west virginia but this is the pakistani
foreign minister
using this line so let's jump into it
this interview taking place right before
the israeli gazan ceasefire was
announced take a look
and the pakistani foreign minister joins
me now from new york mr minister thank
you so much for joining us
it has been a very busy day from your
end
do you hear any talks about a possible
ceasefire coming anytime soon
i am convinced the tide is turning
i am convinced the public pressure
the pressure of public opinion is
mounting
and seized fire is inevitable
israel is losing out they're losing the
media
war despite their connections
they are losing the media wall the tide
are their connections
deep pockets what does that mean
well they're very influential people i
mean they control media
i mean i would call that an anti-semitic
remark
well you see the point is uh they
have a lot of influence and
they get a lot of coverage now what has
balanced that
is the citizen journalist
their connections deep pockets they
control the media
i have to commend bianna golodriga
because she did something that lots of
people won't do
which is just straight up call it what
it is which is anti-semitic
there's often mincing words where the
purveyor of this stuff will use coded
language
and then the person doing the interview
also will use coded language or or mince
words in some way
he goes head first dive right into it
jews control the media with money and
influence
and she says that's an anti-semitic
comment and the foreign minister
is sort of unsure how to respond and he
kind of drifts into something else and
says well let me say this other thing
now what's really nuts and this is
this i don't even know what to what to
call this if you look online at articles
and segments about this segment
it is riddled with even more
anti-semitic comments
saying good for the finance minister for
calling out
jewish control of media there's a huge
contingent
and sadly many are on the american left
who loved what the foreign minister
said it's sad but it's seen as more
acceptable
to be openly anti-semitic at this time
because of the israeli-palestinian
situation which of course
relates to israeli foreign policy which
i find terrible right
i've called out how long have i been
against israeli foreign policy and the
netanyahu administration i don't know
and the reason that there's general
anti-semitism towards
random global jews is because of the
anti-semitic trope
that any jewish person around the world
holds a dual
loyalty to israel and we've talked about
that many times before now by the way
pakistani twitter was cheering this
as if the finance minister the foreign
minister
did the most heroic thing anybody could
have done finally putting the jews in
their place for control of media
as if it's a new and unstated truth that
he's finally willing to say
pakistani twitter users have been
calling the finance minister courageous
brave wise it is jarring
it's not altogether surprising i saw one
nice response to this clip
which was an image of pictures
of jewish elected officials with
stars of david american elected
officials with stars of david
identifying them as jewish it was a
really nice touch you can imagine so
anyway
nice job by bianna golodriga she's
getting absolutely destroyed for this by
pakistani twitter and by others
it's all become quite more brazen lately
i don't remember it ever being as bad as
in the last week
the we we we don't have enough
moderators on any of our platforms to
actually keep up with the anti-semitism
that has exploded here
and uh we'll have a little more about
this on the show's
instagram make sure you're following us
following us there
at david pakman show and follow me on
instagram
at david.pacman we'll take a quick break
next there's somebody now you might be
able to guess who
proposing a real insurrection
not like the one from january 6. that's
after the break